[Aplausos]
se convirtió en Primer Ministro de Reino
Unido el mismo día en el que los
creyentes del hinduismo festejan el
divaly el festival más importante de la
India en el que se celebra el triunfo
del bien sobre el mal la comunidad hindú
en Londres celebró con orgullo la
llegada de sunat al número 10 de Downey
Street
estamos absolutamente emocionados porque
obviamente él es uno de nosotros y lo
que es aún más sorprendente de que se
convierta en Primer Ministro es que
sucede hoy en el dibali que es un día de
Agüero favorable para nosotros
creo que es un momento histórico y de
mucho orgullo para la comunidad india
británica con suerte inspirará la
generación más joven personal de todos
los orígenes étnicos que puedan trabajar
duro y aspirar al cargo más alto
Y es que además de ser el primer Premier
no blanco de Reino Unido también es el
más joven en 200 años pero ocupar el
cargo y será el inquilino más adinerado
de Down Street Él y su esposa estar
entre las mil personas más ricas del
país según el diario de sorman Times
sin precedente que además se recoge todo
el avance lo que fue ese Reino Unido
como Colonia pero a pesar de que tiene
ascendencia India pues no es cualquier
persona digamos que
digamos que es una persona
multimillonaria tiene 42 años Pero
además es el Primer Ministro más rico
que va a tomar ese carro de hecho es
tiene el doble de la riqueza que puede
que podía tener la Reina Isabel
actualmente el patrimonio de Primer
Ministro está en 823 millones de dólares
mientras que la Reina Isabel estaba en
394 millones de dólares la llegada al
poder del ex banquero multimillonario de
origen indio también ha causado revuelo
Pues gobernará un país que colonizó
India gran parte de África y muchos
países más sin embargo
ustedes opinan que es más importante la
efectividad de las políticas que
implemente el nuevo premiere británico
que su origen étnico o creencias
religiosas